Yo no way. Oh my God,
what does success look like?
We found two millionaires and as 10 strangers to tell us who they think is the
more successful one. But we asked our entire audience the same question.
If our strangers choose the same as our audience, they went cold, hard cash.
If they choose the opposite, they win nothing. Welcome to crossing them.
Hello, everybody. Welcome across the Milan. What the game means.
And you've chosen the same person. That's an audience. You win every round.
You will have a chance to switch to the other side.
Although switching to the other side comes with decrease your cash prize.
Every room, that penalty doubles.
We're all absolutely terrified. Middle-class
the first guys in front of wall street. That's the wall street bull behind him.
Yeah, but here's the thing.
I'll show you guys has a tyrant has a literal dinosaur skull next to him, bro.
That's true. Dinosaur Jurassic parks.
So the first one serious, or they expect a millionaire to kind of be,
but the second one is welcoming. Here's the thing. The second one,
the guy in front of the wall street bull. It looks like it's like Photoshop.
What is his watch? No, watch it. Oh, no watches.
Okay. The first one looks like a LinkedIn profile. Like picture like a headshot.
First one looks at younger two.
The first one reminds me more of like a YouTuber rather than I dunno.
It's like the whole homes kind of thing that I like.
If I were to go to YouTube and watch someone
listen to this. Geez, it's hilarious. You got the dinosaur bones.
First person, Sam.
I am going with person to Jonathan or send to da.
I have a good feeling about person too. I'm feeling it in my soul, Adrian.
I am going with the majority person to Ronnie. Uh,
I'm going to go with person one storm, one person to Bryce,
Triston stigma person too. I like the dinosaur Darian. I'll go with person one.
So I'd be going on person one. All right, everybody.
So your initial boats are locked in any switching after this point is going to
result in a penalty. Okay.
I'm looking at GP Stefan and he's with the guy from shark tank.
I think it's Kevin for shark tank. First guy has 1.5 million followers,
crazy 5 million followers. Oh second. Guy's a realtor real estate investor.
Or it turned 12 camp.
YouTube has 2.4 million all over the place.
He's in a private play in the first guy. A lot of things happening right now.
Okay. I think the first guy does stocks. Like that's all I can fight,
but he does charity. You guys often Heim is, is um,
selling sunset on Netflix.
Oh wait by the oftentime group. I'm pretty sure. Yeah. No. The second guy,
he is his, his real real estate company selling sunset associates.
And that's like a TV show. Yeah. He just got a Tesla. I can see that.
I will say, I will say GP. Stefan has more photos with like other people.
He looks like he has more of like a successful life. Not in money,
which is something to consider. First guy seems like he travels a lot.
So there's lots of,
[inaudible] a highlight on donations.
Do you think that the audience likes that? Like someone who's doing charity?
I feel like that could be. I think so.
I think this is the other guy not to a charity. It's not mean.
Yeah. It's not as isolated. Lots of cars on the second guys.
Lots of lots of cars. Very nice house.
The second guy and time is up
now. Would anybody like to cross the line?
I'm crossing the line. I'm crossing the line to Timothy.
I think that might cross the line. Timmy.
It's going good. I have rapid fire questions. One minute and 30 seconds,
gentlemen. There's a lot riding on it. John formalities let's get right to it.
What is it that you do? Your official titles?
I'm a YouTuber real estate investor and real estate agent. Tim,
can you explain what's your job or how you made money? Well,
I'm a stock trader and teacher.
I was in a reality show called wall street warriors.
That was a hit and allowed me to really get into my true love of teaching.
Have you donated any of your money to, um, charities or anything like that?
Absolutely, but I don't post about it. How important is money to you? Really?
It gives you time. You know, freedom.
Like too many people are just working at jobs they hate and they're kind of
wasting their lives away. Just trying to like catch up.
Would either of you categorize yourself as more successful than the other?
I don't know how much you know about each other. You wouldn't say that. Okay.
That's not a good question. Your role model, Joe Rogan for me or Dave Ramsey,
Elon Musk, Richard Branson. Have you had any like struggles?
Both of my parents went through bankruptcy when I was a teenager after I made my
first 2 million in college and I lost a third of it.
It was splashed all over the press and it made me an infinitely better and more
conservative trade.
It was a fast food restaurant that is too expensive for you to be like,
and that's worth it. I think now AAA, because their staples are like seven, $8.
Sometimes I'm just starving.
So I don't even care if it's like five bucks or 50 bucks, I just eat.
What is your net worth? Timothy? Um, I mean,
probably you could call it around 20, 25 million Graham. Wow. Uh,
about 7.3 million. And how old are you? Timothy?
I am 39 and gram 30.
What were you saying your biggest accomplishment in building a YouTube channel
has been one of the most rewarding and challenging things I've ever done in my
entire life.
There'll be 70 schools in my charity so far and teaching other people now.
So I have five millionaire students so far. Um, it's a lot of work,
but education changes lives. Okay. Jonathan time.
Wow. Hi. Hi.
She was strict. That was like a job in rapid fire. I hope I pass
David bro. There might be millionaires, but I need this money bro. Yeah,
that guy said Chipotle. I was like, yo,
Tim said he'll eat anything.
So I got to switch sides because Tim is too financially,
reckless 20 something million and Graham has
7.6 net worth or something like that. Very good. Cute.
I asked about like their background and they said they both like came from like
modest background. Cause that was one thing I was going to do criteria,
but they're basically the same for that.
Timothy was talking about how he was on a TV show called warriors of wall street
for me. He said that and I was like, okay,
well he was already a warrior of gold street in general to have even been on the
show. I also asked like what they think their biggest accomplishment is. And uh,
Graham, I believe said that his was like the YouTube channel,
like building a huge platform. Timothy asks a question.
He dropped the bomb of being able to build somebody schools like,
Oh yeah. I bought some new schools. That's impressive. Impressive.
Now it's your chance to cross the line.
I am crossing the line to Tim. I think I'm going to cross the line with him
diagram. You're really nice. I'm crossing the line to Tim. Oh no trusted.
Some of you crossed the line and sacrifice some of your prize money in the
spirit of ending up on the right side.
And some of you stuck with your guns all the way through,
but there's only one way to win.
And that is being on the side of public opinion.
I guess you guys kind of put yourself in an all or nothing situation. Wow.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I thought no way even going into it, I was like, it's going to
with it. Oh no. I can't believe we all lost.
I'm kind of in shock that we all lost. Everyone wins in this group.
Everyone wins. No, one's a loser.
I'm personally going to give you the money that you would've done
a lot twist. I got another fun one.
I'll add onto that for everyone in the first round,
I'll give you $200,
$201 because Graham doesn't beat me.
Wow. This was crazy.
Invest in stocks. Should I get my realtor license?
Seriously? Thank you. Thank you guys.
Right?